votre fille a été agressée sexuellement
par un proche de nordahl le landais
alors qu'elle n'avait que 13 ans et pour
vous il n'ya aucun doute nordahl le
landais appartient à un réseau c'est en
2010 votre vie va être agressée
sexuellement par son entraîneur de boxe
il devait la ramener après son
entraînement
mais il arrivera avec trois heures de
retard tafer voilà oui effectivement
elle faisait elle faisait partie d'un
club de boxe donc à challes les eaux où
elles étaient entraînés et un soir alors
qu'elle était partie avec sept autres
personnes sept autres gamins on le
trajet a été incohérent et on meurt il
m'a ramené ma fille seule dans le camion
il n'y avait plus aucun autre gamin et à
partir de ce moment là le doute s'est
mis en moins et le trajet me me perturbe
énormément et là je me suis rendu compte
que suite au fait tout ce qui s'est
passé est ce que ma fille a écrit sur
l'ordinateur avec son ami et des
messages lui dit le soir elle est
rentrée donc elle a mis un temps fou
c'est laver pendant je ne sais combien
de temps ensuite elle n'avait pas faim
elle est montée et ce jour là nous avons
deux ordinateurs à la maison et donc
j'ai ouvert ce le deuxième ordinateur
elle avait un compte facebook et je suis
rentré à l'intérieur de ce compte
facebook et en direct j'ai lu où elle
marquait ne reste jamais seul avec
l'entraîneur à son autre petit camarade
de boxe n'aurait jamais seul avec
l'entraîneur j'ai eu trop trop peur et
l'autre petit ludique qu'est ce qui
s'est passé et ma fille lui dit je peux
pas te dire j'ai eu trop peur mais ne
reste jamais seul est là l'autre gamine
lui dit il tu as fait le coup de la
camionnette et ma fille lui dit comment
tu le sais elle lui dit bah moi ça fait
déjà plus d'un an que ça dure donc
là j'ai compris qu'il y avait
effectivement des agressions gg saisi
tout de suite la gendarmerie qui est
venu et puis j'ai lancé la faire avant
que la gendarmerie viennent
j'ai appelé l'entraîneur de boxe il a
décroché et il m'a dit je me dis qu'est
ce qui s'est passé avec ma fille et il
m'a répondu oui j'ai fait une grosse
connerie avec elle donc je savais que ma
fille n'était pas une menteuse je savais
qu'elle n'était pas amoureuse de son
prof je savais qu'il y avait pas toutes
ces histoires là je savais qu'elle avait
été agressée alors on parle de ce club
de boxe dont vous nous avez parlé hier
au lit paurisse un taureau qui était
pour vous un repère mais c'est le club
de boxe où était normale le landais
l'homme dont par le l'or a été condamné
pour exactement quatre agressions
sexuelles alors ça n'a pas été qualifié
en viol ça a été requalifiée en
agression sexuelle puis il a été
condamné à un an de prison ferme
seulement oui mais ils y ont mis un
bracelet il a eu trois ans dont deux ans
avec sursis et un an de fermer comme en
france on ne sait pas de la prison à
faire mais il a eu donc un bracelet et
puis par la suite j'ai prévenu un petit
peu toutes les personnes du club
et là alors là ça a été extraordinaire
les victimes sont devenus des accusés et
l'accusé devenu un mentor oui voilà donc
on a évincé les quatre gamine et on l'a
gardée à lui au club alors qu'il y avait
une interdiction d'entrée né il y avait
une interdiction d'être sur le club de
boxe et tout le monde continuer à cacher
puis après on a même créé une buvette
pour lui autorisé à rester dans la dans
l'enceinte de de la salle de boxe et au
lit le père du propriétaire de la salle
même tracté pour défendre son fils et
faire en sorte que la série continue
dans le pré josé bové ordonne le landais
elle l'a vu on est moins deux fois avec
nous ce type
oui je les ai vus alors gelé vue parce
que cela ça l'était encore particulière
et j'ai jamais compris comment qu'une
mairie aussi importante à l'époque
pouvaient ne pas avoir des vestiaires
séparés pour les hommes et les femmes
donc ballet gamine était
déshabillée il y avait les hommes à côté
c'était quelque chose d'assez